we've never had all the sports firing at
the same time then if you're a sports
fan there's so much to watch right now
what do you think
and i for me there's some sports i
really like it i know this is just me
and i'm not as
obviously i'm a peripheral peripheral
ufc fan
sure i like it without the fans i like
hearing it me too i like hearing the
fight i almost prefer it which is
strange
i prefer it so much more
for me honestly i can concentrate on the
fight more and like what's happening
i love in in some of the body shots that
i wasn't sure
that i wasn't sure i'm like does that
really hurt when you hear it i'm like
i know it's great god also you hear the
coaching yeah like it's
i i think there's not a better product
as far as sports go
without a crowd what sport do you think
as a player
misses the crowd the most that's a good
question it's gonna be football
because if if you're let's say you're
i will use my alumni university of
colorado and you're playing alabama and
alabama's this powerhouse
and you're you're playing at cu you're
playing home field advantage
sometimes you can deal with the momentum
and it might take your team to another
level
you get momentum and you get a fumble
then you you know throw a password
touchdown then you got the momentum
well now there's no momentum yeah the
good team's probably gonna whoop your
ass it's all 99 times out of 100 yeah
like it's like
the good team's gonna win because
there's now there's no momentum there's
no crowd
to inspire the kids like yeah especially
nfl is as pro as it gets they don't give
a [ __ ] about
crowd nothing they're pros do you think
they don't you think basketball do you
think the bat you think that
basketball does basketball's a it's a
better product i think now that
basketball is in this bubble and
everyone's had a chance to get healthy
and there's no crowd so for a team like
the
clippers or the 76ers 76ers were awful
on the road
yeah team on the road and bj simmons was
hurt now they've had rest
there's no road games everything's just
neutral and they're great they were the
best team at home so it's like
now they're a contender you know what
i'm saying so now crazy and then oh the
la clippers when the clippers played the
lakers in la even if they said it was a
clippers
home game and the clippers it said
clippers on the on the court
it was still a lakers home game now that
doesn't matter
now the clippers they don't give a [ __ ]
now nobody's booing or cheering
so the clippers to me would be the
favorite i gotta tell you
i've been watching some of the
basketball and i wish
so the mics that they used to have
closer to the floor it feels like they
took away a little bit you know what i
didn't want you to
hear them swearing correct yeah because
they picked up on lebron a little bit
and i think it's good again a reason why
i like no crowd and a lot of stuff i
want to hear the trash talk dude
i want to hear the trash shop i know but
they they if you notice when the games
fir like
last week thursday night when the lakers
played the clippers or whoever it was
lebron they people didn't realize how
much was [ __ ] talker yes he was saying
[ __ ] and blah blah
and people like oh this is great now
they're like uh uh
this guy's gonna say some [ __ ] they do
but but but you know what
that's kind of like [ __ ] oh come
on my thing is let it go
i want to hear the [ __ ] here's here's
what's interesting you tell me where you
fall on this
so baseball played with it a little bit
where you know everybody took a knee and
you know the brave thing to do now is
actually standing for the anthem crazy
which is
insane the world we live in right now to
each its own
but no one's gone gone harder in the
paint than the nba as far as mixing
politics and sports yeah so when you
turn it on
everybody's taking a knee unless you're
uh george popovich
are you know very few guys uh are
standing for the anthem
but it's black lives matter on the court
i'm fine with that that's what everyone
do
they're jerseys now it's a black lives
matter on the jerseys or
defund the police where the hell they
want to put on their jerseys so now
politics are mixed in with mba because
what the nba is doing is
because it's a younger audience they're
listening to social media yeah they're
going man we got to do something here
but they don't realize social media
isn't the end-all be-all because 1 in 50
people on social media you know that
yeah so if you walk outside right now
150 one in 50 is on twitter
one in 50. so this woke crowd that
doesn't speak for the majority but the
nba
is trying to make those people online
happy so they're doing
mixing politics and sports well what
they don't realize is that's not the
real world it's important but it's not
the end-all be
yeah so more people watch the opening to
the major league baseball than they did
to open to the nba which has never
happened before ever
i i think a couple things now here's my
thing
er i'll i'm gonna watch it regardless i
mean i don't care what the hell they do
but just based off the ratings if you're
uh the commissioner of the nba or your
nba owner
you got to decide what's important
because if it's bottom dollar
you can't mix politics in that politics
that because the nation has spoke and
they didn't tune in because they're sick
of it
here's my thing man and that doesn't
mean that the nation doesn't think black
lives matter that's not important
they just don't want it at that one time
when lebron is facing kauai
they want one outlet where they can just
watch basketball
see i see all of that i also see like
you know it's so funny what we consider
to be political
because the fact that we think black
lives matter
is poli is is now considered politics
is oh is is so crazy to me because that
means
it's drawn are we saying that statement
you have to be on one side or other
politically which i think is crazy
for what they what what it's supposed to
mean but who created that i know but
here's the other thing the president
united states here's the other thing
like
i have articles of clothing that have
the american flag on them
do you know that when i wear those now i
and i walk down the street people will
scream [ __ ] trump to me
because the american flag has somehow
become
political also somehow the if you're
wearing an american flag
you're you're automatically an extreme
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this wrote a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son